this is weird
I am I welcome everybody to http uh guys
I don't know which camera to look at we
have with us here today dr. Eric ding
epidemiologist so I've been following
you on Twitter for a long time I'm not
sure how i came upon your tweets but
ever since this old virus kind of story
broke and wuhan from the very origins
you were sounding the alarms and i was
very keen used to everything you were
saying and i have to say you cut you
have to feel at least a little bit then
I don't want to say vindicated because
it's a horrible thing but you were right
right I mean you were right I know it's
a bittersweet thing first law um I
remember this thing like it was it's
like a fog like like I feel like we're
our friends have been saying like
there's decades in which nothing happens
and then there's weeks in which decades
happen and I feel like January was like
two years ago and now oh yeah it's like
a total blur and I came in like that I'm
like how we even got here and you know I
feel like I've aged so much during that
time and you know that's it along the
way you know I remember when we were
trying to shut down what trying to
petition to shut down Seattle on
comic-con right right I remember that
seems like ages ago was ages ago and
people thought we were crazy
yeah and then now people like oh yeah we
better shut down everything like 90% of
countries let me give some context this
was back in gosh I don't even remember a
Steidle was like hey and it was in
Seattle which was like the origin of the
corona virus in the United States yeah
so Seattle Comicon was like hey guys we
know that there's this corona virus
thing but we are gonna still do
comic-con and and then I first saw it
from you you're like this is insane you
guys have to cancel this and then I
quote tweeted it and you know at the
time
I hear this kind of sentiment echoed a
lot and it's absolutely true it's like
if you're on time people say you are
fear-mongering and if you're on time
you're way too late yeah so how did you
as a early alarm sounding the alarms way
before most I mean how did you respond
to people calling you a fear monger and
a half and all these was it was pretty
rough because like first of all I had
like more inside details than just that
one paper with a big are not on three
point eight which by the way the latest
review can you unpack that what is three
point eight what is three point eight
mean three point eight is like the
reproductive never means for every
infected person that person infects
three point eight additional people and
just for context the reproductive number
of the common seasonal flu is one point
three so three point eight is like
almost three times higher and but it's
not just three times higher its remember
for every infected person three point
eight additional people so this is
exponentially much more than three times
and so I I knew this epidemic was
happening in early January because I had
relatives in China I was rushed and born
there but I'm all American but they tell
me this is weird pneumonia people are
like dying getting sick and people are
panicking and it's like it's a paranoia
no-one's ever like experienced before
and like when you hear that you know
China lots of crazy things happen but to
hear that kind of thing it's not normal
but you know you can't shout just based
on these kind of anecdotes right that's
so interesting it's bad how bad so you
know like grasping for like in for over
how bad and then that paper came out
three point eight and I'm like whoa but
the problem is I at that point I only
had like two thousand followers on
Twitter I was never a big Twitter person
I have I've actually have a 5.5 million
person Facebook page for my cancer
campaign mmm you know I actually didn't
I actually
that Facebook is not the best medium if
you want to reach reporters and world
leaders and influencers you have to use
Twitter but my Twitter was like nothing
so I couldn't just whimper because most
scientists when they post on on Twitter
they just whimper it and it's like um
there's a suggestive evidence that that
potentially could be a possibility of a
no come on no one's gonna listen to that
and so I was like okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna put a little crazy thread together
and it was like before just before my
bedtime I saw this paper like I did a
big deep you know it got out of bed and
I took the deep science and tapped it
out and during that time I tapped out
you one post that was a little bit off
because I misread another paper but um
but I quickly deleted that but the gist
was it's gonna be really really bad and
I knew it was gonna bad because like I
had this other data from China that no
one else had you know you know because
you couldn't find it up on Twitter or he
or American social media it's only on
Chinese social media that my cousin sold
it and so but then people called me fear
monger it's a preprint it's not peer
reviewed yet you know people are like
trying to like that check me where the
lane check was like you're an
epidemiologist but you're not a
infectious disease epidemiologist right
you know the fields of neglect I
actually have a PhD in epidemiology
first which is a slam dunk that's right
up your land that is literally your lane
yeah it is but the thing is they say oh
he has a PhD in nutrition which is true
too because I got a second PhD in
nutrition and then I went to medical
school somewhere along the line I
realized oh [ __ ] went off the deep end
but you know people like also told like
these half-truths like always a
nutritionist
oh he has no which is technically true
but you know it's kind of like what
there's a lie and there's a half truth
and half truths are just as bad as a
lies in time so well welcome to Twitter
I will
tell you it's a it's a hellhole but it
worked I had a lot of pressure and my
people at Harvard were like what the
hell were you doing right and I was like
this is it free speech she's like if I
see smoke I can shout I can stand up and
shout I see there might be fire guys man
there's clearly evidence of smoke
because even the WTO was concerned and
at that point they hadn't declared
emergency so then my next agenda was
like declare a public health emergency
of international concern and that took
like five days but finally they did so
then finally like people kind of woke up
after that but oh by the way in the
middle of that between me tweeting that
and the whu-oh declaring that's when all
the insider trading among those senators
happen you know cuz apparently they got
a briefing around the 23rd or something
so and they sold their stock on the 24th
or 25th and I need it like just a few
days earlier around the 20th so you as
someone who understands the value of
that information they deny having
incited traded can you say from outside
they most definitely like how I can't
say for sure so it's it's proven fact
they had it in there's a special Senate
confidential briefing from like CDC and
NIH leaders so there was definitely a
briefing now the problem is like it's
hard to say whether they truly inside
traitor because hell they could have
read my tweet and then sold the stock I
I don't know and there's other people
there's other news it's not like it's
confidential news it was just it was
just out there in the you just had to
read the tea leaves to find it right and
I doubt the Senators yeah they want that
China yeah who say that way but they did
have a briefing and so that's why it is
a little suspicious but anyways okay
well let's let's back up we've got here
a PhD in epidemiology which is right up
your lane I mean epidemiology is the
study of epidemics right it's it's about
viruses how do you end up
that plane that's a good question how
did I end up in that well I was a normal
kid who played a lot of video games as a
kid I graduated in when I was 18 but
when I was 17 years old they actually
discovered a tumor the size of a
baseball and so he just took out like
several organs took out my thymus part
of my outer sheath of my heart and part
of my right lung because they thought I
had this big cancer and and at first
they thought I had literally was gonna
die in five years because it was uh it
was a they thought it was a non-hodgkins
lymphoma which is pretty terminal
luckily it wasn't but it like the jolted
me awake that god I gotta stop being
this video gamer he's the little kid and
I should do something with my life now
that I got a second chance in life and
so I said I'm gonna go to medical school
so what the happens eh but first we I
fell in love with this thing called
epidemiology was fascinating you can
like look at patterns of disease and you
can statistically adjust for lots of
different things and get the causal
effect of things I was like you know
what I'm gonna put mental school on the
side for pause I'm gonna go get my PhD
in epidemiology so I entered Harvard as
one of the youngest students and in my
doctoral program and then along the way
date a year into it they like hey you
want to do another one in nutrition's
like is that a lot more work
yeah he's the double the work but you
need maybe it's Fried's it's no extra
tuition I was like sure why not and then
um long story short yeah I fell in love
with both I
I wasn't infectious disease
epidemiologist I was a cancer and
diabetes epidemiologist but it's it's
still huge amounts of data under and
along the way I was a whistleblower
against Vioxx the drug that was sold and
killed a lot of people um it was a
billion-dollar Merck drug and we show
them Merck knew about it and and then I
said I want to graduate and they're like
you're kidding me you're 23 years old
and like most people do one of these
software programs in five years you're
doing two of the two of them in two in
two and a half years I was like yeah and
I eventually had to convince my
my advisor my second advisor in the
department chair both epidemiology
nutrition's let me graduate so I
finished both my PhDs in two and a half
years and when I was 23 years old and so
this is me remember I thought I only had
five years left ality so this is like
but I've always been kind of like
chasing like whether it's like this by
ox whistle blowing because they knew
Merck knew about the danger of the Biot
several years it was before was pulled
off the market but they kept selling it
and and if you look at the tea leaves
you know if you flipped one coin for
five coins or it's all heads
maybe it's by chance if you flipped like
20 coins and they're all consistently
heads you know there's something wrong
right and it's kind of like the
intuition you see all that data going
the wrong direction you know see it ends
and that's kind of like me I'm a really
curious guy and I dug into that kind of
thing and so let me let me ask you about
I this is so you're in such a unique
position to comment this as someone who
knows people in China and as a PhD in
epidemiology so I want to start first of
all let's talk about wet markets okay so
we're often hearing that what more a wet
market was the origin of this novel
coronavirus first of all can you explain
to me what is a wet market wet market is
something you don't have in the states
it's basically a market we buy live
animals like live chickens live ducks or
contrived yields you know to eat like
instead of like going to a grocery store
and airs up Purdue chicken that's like
you know chill air chilled in this
plastic packaging there is a chicken
grab it's by neck or you want this
chicken okay that cut its head off and
you pluck off their feathers and then
you take it home so what is so dangerous
about these wet markets yeah because
you're literally like cutting off
chickens heads and cutting off like you
know you're literally slaughterhouse
it's like a live slaughterhouse in front
of you it's like I would like three eels
to
ducks and this you know this other weird
animal that whatever it is that they're
trading pangolins or something and so
it's literally a lie of slaughterhouse
and they slaughter the animals in front
in front of you when whether it's fish
or these other of farm animals and so
it's a very different thing where most
Americans can't even imagine it's very
bloody it's very nasty it's just it's
just how it is it's it's fresh from the
market literally so what what is so what
is so dangerous about these wet markets
are they responsible for breeding
for example the corona virus it's
another viable first of all there's a
lot of feet gold matter you know the
animals are there with a poop and poop
carries a lot of viruses and and of
course you're exchanging animals they're
like penned up together they're not it's
not like a zoo where all these animals
have space to roam they're literally
locked in cages and or just thrown in
big cages all together so they are
basically really close together animals
the animals and people are grabbing them
you know sometimes you chase around the
chicken during a catch one and you grab
one and you try to like oh you want this
one no I want that one you put it down
you pick up another and so it's you're
literally touching all these different
animals and this is what allows
potentially a you know a buyers to jump
between you know a you know a bat and a
chicken and uh mmm you know duck and
some frogs and then jump to you and so
it is uh it's a circus so that's why
it's very plausible it came from there
at the same time you know who knows it
in China
you couldn't literally come from
anywhere because the population density
is just so high and people go out into
the wilderness to hunt and bring back
food as well so do you think that these
wet markers should we shut down by China
or do you think that it's just kind of a
fact of life over there
what's the solution here like they are
shutting them down but it's it is really
hard to divorce you know because what
what
it's probably like getting into like a
gun topic here like part of the culture
right and well what I've heard is that
the wet market industry like you were
saying it's hard for Americans to fathom
but they're it's like you know several
hundred billion dollar industry there
that provides food to like a large
percent of the population of China
because there's just so many people to
feed so it's not something that you can
easily just shut off it's not something
it's not like a pastime it's actually
people need these these wet markets to
eat because there's so many people there
yeah there is and grocery stores and
it's not what you imagine it's not Whole
Foods it's not even like giant or stop
by Safeway it's it's it's a very
different world so I think food to
sanitation hygiene it's a different
culture you know it's so is it not it's
naive in other words for for us
Westerners to start demanding China to
close now I realize for example China
has half the farmland as a US but it has
four times of population so every square
inch of land every acre has to feed
instead of one person in us as a feed
eight people in China for the same
amount of farmland and there's in so
farming intensities incredibly dense
it's just and you have to feed these
urban centers at Wuhan as a city would
probably like be the second largest city
in America right now you know and but in
China it's just a city that's yeah so I
think I think that's something
interesting to keep in mind is just how
different it is you know the wet market
sounds like a terrible place honestly
for me I think I if I walked there I'd
be I would be horrified but it's just a
fact of life over there
so what did what about this thing people
keep saying it came from bats is there
any truth to that the corona virus come
from a dude eating bat soup no it
doesn't come from bat soup cuz you can't
eat it from us get it from the soup yeah
first of all the soup by definition
kills the viruses says it's cooked
because this virus degrades very easily
in heat and humidity the issue is it's
similar to the bat but at the same time
you you could it's more like a cousin of
the bat so a cousin of means likely
there's there's a common ancestor in
which from it diverged right like you're
related to your cousin not from your mom
but from your grandmother so the issue
is who's who's this grandparent species
that you jumped from and you can tell by
the viruses evolved this is actually by
the way how we know that in the
Washington state when the outbreak
finally was discovered not just the
first case but the outbreak they
realized he actually was derived from
that same case and you know that cruise
ship off the coast of California that
who ship was also derived from the
Washington case because you could see
how it arrived it came from the cruise
ship the cruise ship came from the
Washington State case not from another
one of the new cases from so was already
here it was already here interest and
you can tell by the evolutionary lineage
so the evolutionary lineage show that
yes it's close to that but there's minis
we need to find a direct ancestor and we
still have not found the direct ancestor
yet maybe if we just hunt for more bats
eventually we'll find it but we haven't
found it yet and to really like disprove
any conspiracy theories about you know
bioengineering the ultimate the Holy
Grail is to find this immediate ancestor
and sometimes I first they thought it
came from from camels or something but
they're like two years later they
eventually found that it actually came
from Jordan
from different species of animals so the
cannibals was just a camel's rooster
reservoir but you need to find a direct
ancestor not the cousin of ancestor you
know and the bats are like right now the
closest that version is a cousin of it
I see and so what I think you touched on
there briefly is that in wuhan there is
an institute institute of Urology there
and there are conspiracy theories that
claim that this virus is potentially
man-made and the weapon as well as it
could been as a weapon it could have
just asked someone there accidentally
got infected it was an accident and then
you know so so is there any credence to
that there's just as much as that as it
was aliens like there's no proof like
it's like circumstantial evidence like
you murdered someone because you were
attending the same party in which this
person disappeared from well there's a
hundred there's hundreds of people who
were also there just because I was there
also there doesn't mean that I just
because I was near it attending the same
ball ball room party that I was holes is
not miscible in court of law and again
it is in China it's such a high density
of things you know that's not even
problem it's not even like Wuhan is a
major city it has the biggest wet
markets and it's one of the most
industrial centers it's also where lot
of pharmaceutical companies are also
made and it's an industrial heartland
and that's why they also had this major
Institute of biology there you know if
for some reason like if this was like in
Tibet and this epidemic started in this
teeny tiny corner of remote Tibet and
own their biologist who's also in their
part of remote Tibet maybe but this is
like Luhan is like everything's in it's
like New York City everything it was
like a met 11 million people live there
right yeah exactly when you think about
like the city of the size of New York
it's like well of course there's an
institute of neurology and this
city of New York is a huge city it's not
a big deal because like there's so many
things in New York and so many things in
DC you so many things again I think it I
think it really just comes from from not
understanding China it's the same thing
as the sweat market it's hard to imagine
it's just such a different world it
seems like out there well again if
there's no you're staying as a chance
like there is we haven't solved like and
I again I am absolutely not conspiracy
theorists like there is years ago
someone did engineer the old Soros want
you know the two in the SARS epidemic
2003 in 2009 until 10 in a Proceedings
of National Academy of Science a major
journal someone did insert a few like
mutations just for fun to see if they
could make the old SARS more virulent
and they did and and this mutation the
inserter was a Furion and and so the old
SARS never had it but to somehow the new
SARS has won and so the question is how
did that one get there and so what we
need to find is the animal that carried
it it's very easy to like have these
mutations you know there's just like a
few amino acid it's very natural it can
easily happen but again we kind of need
to find the host animal that was a
direct ancestor of it to really put it
away but again at this point right now
it's it's almost moot like you know it's
a pandemic
it's killing everybody in every single
country and I think um you know we'll
let the biologist Duke it out and
there's no point
it's speculating or chasing it because I
thought there's there's no other
evidence there's no evidence in any way
or shape or form whatsoever and it's
kind of pointless to argue it so I am
absolutely absolutely for the last time
against any conspiracy theories I think
it's a waste of time to you're over and
give it more air let me ask you this how
does a bet how does like let's say a bat
give
human a virus is it like breath isn't
breathing poop
so some so someone someone you touch and
then and then he touched his mouth or
something like that that would they I
don't know and is that true how is that
true also of other when new viruses
enter like cross yeah very common it's
all the study in bats and people who are
actually in contact with that there's
remote villages are very close to these
bat caves okay and they thought like oh
and then they discovered like these bats
had like hundreds of viruses and they're
like what's a chance that it jumped into
these villages that are adjacent to them
and someone did an experiment and they
realized these people were caring like
dozens and dozens of these corona
viruses and other viruses that means
these bats were caring and and it just
so happened that most of them were mild
viruses right we're just kind of inert
and just carry it and so in some ways
like that just proves like we just found
like a remote village that had hundreds
of dozens or hundreds of these bat
viruses there exists in that population
and these people were living with it it
just so happened it didn't kill them at
a high rate so and that case supports
the fact that it probably came from
another animal and it's just this one
luck unlucky virus hit us and is this is
this particular virus the co vid
nineteen is this a particular malicious
virus does this kind of transmission in
other words does this kind of
transmission happen fairly commonly and
this is just the rare exception where
it's actually quite deadly and
contagious or just a rare occurrence
this is the exception because as I was
saying like they found so many other
viruses that these people in these
villages next cities kate are these bat
caves were having it
just literally you know this wet markets
been around for you know years for you
know decades and it just finally we got
unlucky and one of a really bad one
jumped from animals to humans and Bob's
your uncle Bob your uncle yeah so what
happens if let's say there's a lot of
talk and the United States uh kind of
comes and goes but there's a lot of
politicians because it's easy to look at
the economy and when when the world
shuts down it's easy to see the media
damage and impact of shutting the whole
economy down I mean just Burton for
example today another six point six
million people claimed unemployment for
a total I think there's like ten percent
now the official number is probably much
higher than that of unemployment in the
United States though it's easy to look
at that and say as shrimp and his some
of his associates say is we can't let
the Cure be worse than the disease which
is I've heard that phrase you Sorrell
comes to chemotherapy and stuff like
that so they're kind of they're kind of
comparing it to like you know some kind
of barbaric cure what is what does it
look like if we just say you know what
it's got a two percent mortality rate
let's just continue living let it's do
its thing we've live with the flu this
isn't much worse than the flu let's just
like it's just not worth shutting down
the world go oh just let it do its thing
yeah so what does that look like how bad
is that
yes yeah at this argument by the way
first of all oh it's you either destroy
the economy or just you know kill a lot
of people I don't I don't think it's
like an either/or black and white thing
and I'll explain why so first of all if
you let it just do its course and let
nature have its way with us without
doing any containment mitigation or lock
downs or whatsoever you know it's not
just a deaths by the way is two percent
deaths if you are treated and keep it
contained but
you know the death this mortality this
case fatality ratio it's not a set
amount you know basically what happens
is that you know if you don't treat
anyone with ventilators right if a
country has no ventilators like your RAM
and it's really really high in mortality
or if you run out of ventilators that
you're out of your over capacity you're
out of oxygen tanks which by the way a
lot of these hospitals are also running
low on oxygen tanks where all these
patients then those people will die and
so but if you keep it in check when you
and you have be able to treat enough
people then it's lower so and what
happened is like you know Italy is
approaching like nine ten percent
mortality and same in like France and
the reason is they're just completely
swamped you know this is a flatten the
curve thing they're completely over
health hospital capacity and any excess
is what we're out of ventilators you die
um and even ventilators by the way is
not enough for them so it is quite an
insidious infection usually guests
before modern science if this kind of
virus swept through let's say 300 years
ago what kind of mortality rate would we
would we be looking at we'll probably
have like you know 15 15 20 % Wow so
that is that is but because look a lot
of people have shortness of breath right
and right now a lot of the shortness of
breath can be ameliorated by oxygen
there's oxygen like in a mask and
there's oxygen like up your nose right
up your nose down down directly and then
you know there's intubation and then we
have ECMO machines which is
extracorporeal which means outside of
your body membrane oxygenation
it's like kidney dialysis but instead of
dialysis it's to give you oxygen in your
blood so you know instead of cleaning
your blood is to give your oxygen blood
outside into a machine and then puts it
back inside you mmm that's pretty insane
yeah that sounds pretty oh yeah
and most hospitals only have like a
you if if at all rural hospitals don't
have any and they're real expensive and
really labor-intensive to to maintain to
work for someone to use it so again we
have all this modern medicine sometimes
we can't treat we can treat the symptoms
but we can at least prolong people's
lives and yeah long time ago if it's
just you know we were just like destroy
a lot this is what kind of the bubonic
plague was the Black Death plays Wow
so you think it's be you put this on the
same level the exact same level not on
the same level
well Iowa I'm saying is uncheck remember
that the the Spanish flu which is not
really Spanish it's just they just Spain
did the best testing and they found it
the the the the flu influenza of 1918
the one that ravaged the world during in
the middle of World War one it killed
like millions and millions and millions
of people I think up to like
double-digit millions in the teens yeah
but you know in the middle of World War
one there's no like it was like a long
signal yeah but this could easily be
like that and again also a mames a lot
of people like they're they're scarred
and these people who are on ventilators
some of them for like four weeks in
China and here in the States as well
like it's there like disabled for a long
time it takes a lot of time for them to
recover and so I want you to think about
this a it will kill a lot of people not
just 2% but above 5% maybe 10% if you
just let it just blow through a
population you'll disable a maim a lot
of people like you know they there's
they'll be so weak that they won't be
able to go to work right and again it's
not just old people like in the CDC
report just last week compared to
someone with no risk factors someone
with diabetes has 17 fold higher odds of
being emitted at ICU
a diabetic person is 7 a diabetic person
who gets infected versus non died but
person
healthy 17 higher fold chance of MIT
being admitted to ICU that's insane
that's larger than smoking causes lung
cancer you know that's more than obesity
causes diabetes it's seven you know odds
ratio 17 relative risks and 17 is just
off the charts very dangerous for this
is also the problem like in the South
right now you know the South is known
for the stroke belt a lot of diabetes
their mortality is much higher even in
young people then compared to like the
young young adult mortality and like
other New England states or Colorado
young adult mortality in the south is
right really high and it's it's because
that that there's so many other
comorbidities you know you know COPD
asthma smoking diabetes high blood
pressure is also a major killer of kovat
um of Kobe patients heart disease you
need to add him up between anyone who
has either asthma diabetes heart disease
high blood pressure heart you know
kidney damage liver disease you know any
sort of emphysema or any sort of any of
these diseases and now who's left who's
who doesn't have it in the US especially
in the deep south that's not many people
left everyone almost everyone in the
deep south I'm not I'm saying everyone
but a large majority I'll say more than
50% maybe even two-thirds have one of
these risk factors that will put them in
severe debilitating State in the ICU at
best and so now to answer your question
well what will happen a lot of people
will die a lot of people will also
completely so verse over swarm the
hospitals and be on ventilators for like
weeks and weeks because actually in
certain ways
someone who enters a hospital and dies
immediately or someone never enters the
hospital and dies at home costs almost
no money right but someone who's into
ICU hospitalized in a bed for like weeks
and weeks a week's cuse you know
hospital bill
in lots of the hospital bills and then
the hospital beds and then if you have a
heart attack or if you had a stroke and
you need to go the ER and you need to
get emergency surgery a bypass surgery
or some others or some other major
procedure to save your life but the ER
is full guess what you're gonna die too
even though you don't have Kovac might
give you a diabetic blood sugar
emergency asthma allergy emergency any
other sort of opioid overdose you're
going to die too because the ER and the
hospital beds are full and this is the
problem it will literally a directly
kill because of the virus and your risk
factors that puts you a high chance of
dying or being debilitated but also kill
people who don't even have the virus at
all but they'll die of cancer heart
attacks strokes over drug overdoses it
sounds like such a terrifying hellscape
that once it starts ravaging then people
are gonna be so terrified and scared to
go outside the economy is gonna be
shutting down even worse exactly so my
answer is it's not you're choosing
between saving lives and saving the
economy saving lives will also save the
economy because you may have them home
and keeping them relatively healthy at
home until this thing is over right
because you're you know there's a
hurricane outside you either throw
everyone in the hurricane and let half
of them get you know killed by a flying
you know branch or you keep everyone
inside until the storm is over right and
then you know you can go back to work so
this is this premise that we hear is is
isn't in european-- not a true print not
an accurate premise at all it's it's one
there's only one way out really which is
to defeat the virus on that on this very
uplifting note we're we're not a break
time so let's take a quick break and we
can jump right back in alrighty so we
will be right back with dr. Erica ding
we'll continue our discussion about
covered 19 and all things virus here on
the h3 podcast
thank you to stamps.com for sponsoring
this episode for all of our sake we must
be avoiding crowds now you have a better
excuse than ever to be using stamps calm
why go to the post-office and catch
coronavirus when you can do it online at
stamps calm forget I mean you know
that's in addition to the discounts and
the money-saving that you'll get through
Sam calm you can print posters on demand
skip lines crowds it's much more
convenient and also you will survive
survival above all Sam calm brings all
the services of the US Postal Service
right to your computer and the safety
and comfort of your home office or
anywhere else you are hunkering down
right now whether you're a small
business sending invoices or an online
sellers shipping our product are you
just working from home and need to mail
stuff stamps calm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 or any letter
any package any class mail anywhere you
want to send once your mail is ready you
just leave it for your mail carrier
schedule a free pick-up or drop it off
in the mailbox no human contact is
required it's that simple and like I
said with stamps comm you get great
discounts - that's five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off USBs
shipping rates
that was not part of the copy read that
was my own ad-lib and now in addition to
offering discounted US Postal Service
rates samsung also offers UPS services
with discount rates up to 62% well plus
with stamps.com you won't even have to
pay UPS residual surcharge stamps comm
is a no-brainer
especially now saving you time and money
and keeping you safe in these crazy
times so for our listeners go to to get
a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment just go to Sam's comm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in h3 that stamps comm
enter h3 stay safe my friends with
stamps calm
you know I love that quip electric
toothbrush quip the makers of the quip
electric toothbrush want you to know the
one single discovery that matters the
most for your dental care it is simply
this that if you have good habits you
are good that means that brushing for
two minutes twice a day and flossing
regularly no matter what brand you use
quick makes it simple starting with an
electric toothbrush refillable floss and
anti cavity toothpaste clips electric
brush has a sensitive sonic vibration
with a built-in timer and 30-second
pulses the guy of full and even clean
the quip floss to Spencer comes with
free mark string to help you use just
enough plus quip delivers fresh brush
heads
flush flush play offs and toothpaste
refills to your door every three months
with free shipping so your routine is
always right and your mouth as always
freaking clean join over 3 million
healthy mouth and get equipped today
starting at $25 only this is the way to
go
equip electric toothbrush I'm just gonna
give you my personal endorsement right
now I don't use any other toothbrush
because the bristles are soft
I made a rubber gentle my gums gives me
a perfect brush it tells me exactly how
long I need to brush it's it's it's the
best brush in the game and at 25 dollars
you're not gonna find a better brush
they got a special offer if you gotta
get quit calm /ht 3 right now you get
your first refill for free that's your
first refill free at get quick calm /h 3
spelled GE t qu i p.com /h tree that's
quit the good habits company mal right
so we are we are back with dr. Eric Dane
here with us I keep looking between the
cameras though it was my first zoom
interview so so we were just we were
talking about the false premise of we
can fix the economy and the virus it
doesn't seem like that is an option and
that the way you described is actually
even worse than I imagined I and and
well people have been saying from from
the very beginning well you know our
very own president only I don't know
like seems like years ago now but was I
don't know if it was a month or even
less said that you know the flu kills
50,000 people a year we don't we don't
even worry about that this is not this
is even as bad as the flu what what do
you what do you how do you react when
you hear people saying that you know
it's just the flu oh that line here I
have 10 different points well I think
what we just spoke about pretty much
shut that point down but first of all
here's the differences we already taught
the reproductive number the flu has a
1.3 reproductive number and this one has
anywhere between 2 and 4 you know and
there's a new study that just said it
was a 5.7 so it's hot
let's just say it's wait it's it's at
least twice if not three times higher in
reproductive coefficient and again for
every cycle instead of one point three
additional people it's three additional
people so it spreads much faster the flu
many of you actually have background
immunity because you've had the flu
before you've had us a related cousin of
the that this year's strain so you have
some partial immunity the flu also you
have a vaccine now it's not perfect
every year because the flu mutates
really fast this is why it's hard we
have to gather new vaccine every year
but at least is 50 percent effective
this year most years it's like 75 80
percent effective so that's a huge
difference that's three points of
difference right there the flu has a
mortality a point one this one if it's
contained
has a mortality at least 1% if not 2 to
3% and if it's uncontained you know in a
runaway situation he'll go way above 3%
and again even 1% means it's 10 times
deadlier 3% means 30 times deadlier and
and the other thing is the flu does not
spread a symptomatically
which means before you even have
symptoms it's not a word and neither
will did their old SARS so for example
if you flew on a plane you thought
perfectly healthy and two days later you
know fly into LA to do a your your
interview and then you know you feel
sick you only have to quarantine those
around you when you are sick not
everyone on the plane we're at the
airport when you're still healthy the
problem with this virus is it spreads
even when you have no symptoms so even
when you thought you were healthy and
you're just you're coughing we're just
spitting when you talk everyone spits
when they talk you're actually
transmitting the virus to other people
again some people are much more
susceptible so this and apparently now
then it seems at least there's at least
25% of the people who are completely
asymptomatic in Iceland which is the
king of testing for this just for
comparison
Iceland tests 5000 tests per 100,000
people the u.s. does about 3 400 tests
per 100,000 people we're worth at least
tenfold lower than Iceland and so and
there they had discovered that 50% of
the people when they detect us so many
people
50% of people are asymptomatic which
means this virus is literally spreading
again we know it's as spreading
asymptomatic it's spreading silently in
our population and the flu we also have
treatment Tamiflu there are many other
known treatments or drugs for the flu
for this one up until now we have no
proven treatments that
really really work in that we know for
sure works and know how much the works
but it depends on what kind of treatment
there's existing drugs which you know
we'll get to hydroxychloroquine and
there's other drugs like for HIV and
hepatitis C for other viruses that we're
testing there we we have some hope that
because they're already on the market we
just have to retest it for this one as
opposed to developing a brand new drug
that takes longer
um this is why the vaccine takes long
because vaccine you have to go through
the early safety testing and then the
efficacy testing and then you know but
now for the existing drugs you can just
test
oh we know it's safe let's just test it
for the propane's Cova death so you know
we for read us earlier the drug we might
get results in like two three weeks that
said it is a lot of these hepatitis C
and HIV drugs are really expensive and
that's the problem so we still have n
hydroxychloroquine it's cheaper but it's
very limited supply it's originally only
for people with malaria which almost no
one in America has or lupus which is
really rare so we don't have enough
supplies of them and they have extreme
side effects which again some people are
very very susceptible some people are
fine but we need to know like does the
known extreme side effects outweigh and
the benefits for it so we'll hopefully
have drugs much faster than we'll have
have vaccines and you know one of the
things I'm trying to work on is actually
trying to speed up the drugs there are
there are a lot of bureaucratic route
loopholes like right now the fastest
thing you can do to find a drug is hey
all you doctors and seeing hundreds of
patients in New York City I'm gonna give
you guys you guys have like literally
like thousands of patients a day right
I'm gonna give you guys a dis truck and
give you guys a placebo
randomly and then in one week two weeks
max you go be able to tell me if the
drug works theoretically if we had a
drug that's already on the market
let's just say vitamin D that's what I
would do because vitamin do you prevent
cytokine storm for other pneumonias I
would do that but to actually carry out
that trial there is like a boatload of
bureaucracy yeah they're valid they need
to go through the FDA go through this
institutional review board you have to
pay the fees to the hospitals and the
universities you have to and then you
have to wait get wait for clearance I'm
not any for the liability and if the
patients get sick under your watch as a
while doing a trial technically the
trial has to pay for it but all these
red tape could be just cut you know
they're already in the hospital anyways
right if they waive all these
requirements speed up their approval and
New York does not have to wait for FTA
theoretically you could do it much much
faster good right we need to be doing
that now you know the federal government
says marijuana is illegal right but a
lot of state says it's it's okay
so there's many states in which it
conflicts a federal law federal law says
it's illegal state says no it's fine and
if New York did that and basically start
waving a lot of these requirements you
could easily get you could easily get
trials done very fast and then if he
told hospitals stop charging fees all
your doctors are on the front of front
lines make it part of your job to test
these drugs it would literally we could
get results in under three or four weeks
theoretically yeah I'm very fascinated
by this whole issue with kovat 19 that
it's able to transmit during this
incubation period when you're
asymptomatic yeah is that is that rare I
mean how does that work is this
something that you see commonly yeah is
it it's really common it's
well-established we saw it happening in
January and February
and but now there's like a mountain of
evidence I think there's like ten
studies that confirms this now it's it
is like it's not even a hypothesis
anymore it's confirmed this is why I see
my events max in other words in other
words how how rare is this quality and
viruses because it seems so insidious it
seems to make a virus so much more
dangerous how common is this it's a rare
thing not many the old SARS did not have
it the flu generally doesn't have it
there are some that have has it but um I
don't think it's it's it's not common
it's just it's just somehow very
infectious it's more of a property of
some viruses like like like Ebola or the
old SARS
you only got sick from someone if they
are extremely extremely extremely sick
and then they COFF on you with our very
high viral load their very extreme sick
state then you'll get it hmm in this
state people have a viral load and
they're shedding it all shedding these
viruses from the body all the time and
it seems that you catch a little bit of
it from a mildly person sick person or
asymptomatic person you will get it it
just seems that the virus particle just
hooks on much faster and there's some
evidence that basically this virus binds
by its receptors in your lung mush with
a stronger affinity it's like a sticky
or much stickier glue right so if it's a
much stickier glue you only need much
fewer particles to really induce
something you know we don't know the
exact dynamics but we know it's much
more infectious and the other thing with
incubation is you know how they always
say isolate yourself quarantine for 14
days
well that was based on an early study in
China but they did a reanalysis of some
other things and one study says one in a
hundred people will have an incubation
period longer than 14 days which
incubation is from the time you get
infected to time you show symptoms and
know that you are sick
it's longer than 14 days and the point
of the quarantine period is that if
we're not sure if you're sick if you are
in contact with a friend who was sick
your quarantine for 14 days if you don't
show symptoms hey you're okay you're in
the clear without even doing a test
you're gonna clear but there's a lot of
people who basically get sick much
longer outside of a 14-day window and
this other study said 12% of people who
are infected develop symptoms beyond the
14 days so yeah that is a potential
right do you think so what do you think
the quarantine should be I mean Cal how
can we start quarantine people for like
30 days that seems so right yeah it's
just it's the problem is like for
example that the first california case
at UC davis that person who was
transferred back and forth and you know
finally got her tests after like a long
arduous argument she got tested positive
finally in the ICU but by then she like
a hundred and twenty UC Davis health
care workers had to be like put out of
commission for two weeks because they
were in close contact without masks and
everything and many of them did come
down with the virus so this this this
thing is you know it's serious like the
other key examples you know though
remember the diamond princess ship on
for Japan I like to tell people this
anecdote the Japanese quarantine officer
he's a quarantine officer he knows about
infections he just he goes on the ship
to inspect on there for a few hours
comes off the ship few days later test
positive
he's a quarantine officer right and he
knows how to take care of himself and
protect himself test positive another
Japanese firefighter who's transporting
really sick passengers to the hospital
from the ship to the hospital was was
protected after moving the transporting
them he test positive
even though he was protected it's just
one of the most of contagious diseases
you've ever come across it's pretty
contagious look measles is more
contagious measles has are not like a
bug Ted Wow okay so there's a whole
nother stratosphere but the difference
is most of us are immune because we have
a vaccine for it let's go
you know in actuality it's in today is
not as dangerous you know
if we had no vaccine for it and we had
no immunity to it it would be definitely
death no more dangerous but we have a
vaccine and with most of us have
immunity o side note for all those who
are thinking about not taking the
measles vaccine here's a little
interesting factoid for you
unlike other infections so what normally
if you you know get the flu or a common
cold your body remembers it your body
has memory b-cells so next time I see it
I recognize it aha I'm gonna go into my
memory b-cell archive bring out the
antigen that recognizes it and attack it
right away and you won't get sick and
this is what immunity is right
I've seen this virus before my body's
built up resistance attack so all these
like memory b-cells hold all these old
viruses that you've previously fought
off hundreds if not thousands of viruses
that you've had ever since you're a kid
to the adulthood
probably had been sick you know with
hundreds of viruses well if you get
measles the measles wipes out that
memory bank that's not good disease
you've built up resistance to it deletes
that entire resistance memory bank in
your b-cells and that's why measles is
extra bad so please vaccinate don't get
measles because it will it will destroy
all your life's work I'm coding over
this I wonder how anti-vaxxers are gonna
be after this and then like oh they're
gonna take that they're gonna take that
this is going to change their minds
well what how do you convince an
anti-vaxxer to get a measles shot I mean
I mean well short of a pandemic let's
hope that maybe this wakes them up a
little bit they were just living a
little too cliche to like look you know
a lot of the argument that the vaccine
company the the anti-vaxxers say is oh
it's just a corporate scheme to get rich
it's a it's big pharma scheme or it's
like these big billionaires in the world
profiteering from it these these you
know world leaders sitting in their
thrones how can we profit let's start
let's make people backside no think
about who's dying like you have famous
famous people who are like dying rich
super rich people who are dying
you have the Prime Minister you have the
Prince Charles give Tom Hanks am Idris
Elba yeah like everyone is getting it
it's like it's it's not like some
conspiracy like and look we're shutting
down we're literally killing our economy
and you know spiking millions of
unemployment and stock market tanking
and the GDP crashing that's not in
certain ways that blows up any of this
like corporate conspiracy theory about
about the vaccines that it was all a big
for-profit scheme no no one's profiting
from this vaccine right now no one in
their right mind figure no they'll
figure out some some explanation for why
not today I wonder if scientists and
people who do what you do people like
you if you get personally offended when
people are like anti-vaxxers it's like
we work it is really in your face really
your life's work yeah yeah it is it is
yeah luckily there's something called
herd immunity that if we immunize enough
people it's got her to meetings like for
example if you're in a crowded room
you're on this side of the room I'm on
this far side you have the virus I don't
but if most the people in the middle of
the room most of them by most I mean
depending on the virus but like eighty
ninety percent of them have
immunity then the chance of that buyers
hop skipping through the room to me is
low right but if only 50% of people have
immunity
oh that buyers is still gonna hop skip
on its way and to skip to me
right so that's herd immunity if enough
people have immunity so they they have
the luxury of being anti-vaxxers because
we back today yeah they have the luxury
that if we enough taxi right but it's
dropping so much in some places that
hence you have these measles vaccine
about outbreaks again these whooping
cough what do you think of that when you
see that you're like there's there's
there are outbreaks of measles and
whooping-cough I mean what honestly do
you make of that I think it's really
responsible it's it's like how I see you
know these people going on spring break
in the middle of a pandemic right and
having coughing parties and like what
are you doing but so so the but the
singers the problem is that the way you
just described the virus to me unchecked
is a horriffic there's a [ __ ] really a
horrific sight that nobody would want
these kids they they listen to the media
the president there's a lot of people
downplaying the severity and frankly
also on the ground they're like hey I
don't see anyone sick everything's good
here everyone's fine
so it's it's I just unfortunately it's
almost like a failure of imagination and
it seems or just of Education well it
seems like this kind of pandemic you can
correct me if I'm wrong but you have
this global pandemic like once every 100
years and we we these these kids and
even I mean people most people living
today can't tell you what it was like to
live through the Spanish flu and so how
can that's alive right I mean so how can
really grasp that what we're dealing
with yeah so I think first of all people
there's thing in public health right now
like vaccines normally when they work
like they're so effective like for
example let's take us something that's
more like
less abstract if look a hundred people
gets injured or run over by cars at this
busy la intersection gosh we've better
put in a crossing signal or a sky
walking bridge right and then after you
put in as crossing signal or a sky
bridge the next year almost nobody gets
run over at this intersection anymore
but we paid for and then they're like oh
we've wasted all that money putting the
stupid sky bridge and putting the stupid
traffic light here not what we were
doing you know such a waste but thing is
if public health interventions are
successful the whole point is nothing
happens right and P and you you are
exactly right on the failure of
imagination because you know people
appreciate medicine because met doctor
czar like mechanics your car breaks down
your body breaks down they fix it give
you some medicine give you some surgery
and then ah thank you doctor you fixed
my car you fixed my body but in public
health you know the whole point is that
you don't even get sick you don't get it
that our car accident you don't get that
measles you don't get the heart attack
that sends you to the ER in the first
place and everyone's blissfully ignorant
right and then no one says thank you who
do I thank for putting for saving my
life today I like well even and marsh
get they will they'll call you a fear
monger yeah you're actually trying to if
Public Health intervention was
successful and everyone had heard my big
alarmist ringing of the whistle and the
blowing the horn and this epidemic was
stopped in its track they would have
called me a fear monger because it
publicly had cessful the outcome is
nothing happened that's the taifa cotton
yeah it's a tough job and that's what's
happening with that seem like no one
remembers of measles whooping cough what
is that right oh yeah whatever
no one has that anymore it's like you're
making that up
when tastic right you know it's the
right it's it's it's dank em
but in a way you know maybe I think the
world is kind of it seems like reacting
fairly well to this pandemic compared to
what the absolute worst case scenario
could be is that it seems like we even
though we did get caught off guard and
reacted slowly on the whole the world is
working together each country seems to
be doing you know at its own pace the
relative believe the right thing even
here in the United States every state is
kind of I mean obviously some slower
than others yeah
seem to be doing the right thing and so
it's just uh I mean it seems much better
than if this happened a hundred years
ago
well yeah can still work because they
can work from home and work remotely
right and you know I it's a you
mentioned about you know every state has
different like lock downs the problem is
that out we're all so much more mobile
than a hundred years ago we'd fly a lot
our cars move way faster than horse and
buggies 100 years ago right our trains
are faster and so what happens is like
in the old days if you had an epidemic
in Louisiana it'll take a while before
it goes to Alabama Texas New York and
all the other places but now one spring
break trip in Florida can spread all
these spring breakers across the country
and we've actually seen cell phone data
home of these Miami Spring Breakers and
their cell phone signals of where they
went to after that weekend was over and
the problem with the u.s. is like not
every state has a good lock down so
think of a ship if a ship has 50 holes
and like 25 of the states 25 of the
holes were plugged where even 30 or 40
of this holes were plugged with
lockdowns the ship is still sinking
right because the water will still get
in from the other holes is still flood
the interior of the country interior of
the ship and so because we have no real
borders and
can't put a border and between New York
and New Jersey and New York and
Connecticut it's just there's no such
thing as a border there so you could
have as tight of a lockdown but if your
neighboring state does not have a lock
down the ship is still sinking and
taking on water through the other holes
and that's the problem
so are you do you see a failure at the
federal level to our it is our efforts
here in California wasted because of
Florida's for example refusal to shut
down their state yeah it's not entirely
wasted I will not say wasted but it is
much less effective than it could be if
we're all like on the team
hey I plug my hole you plug your hole
and then we all stop this ship from
sinking right taking out more water so
which which states are currently not
locked down for example can Kansas
Kansas governor had ordered lockdown but
the Republican legislature yesterday
over through her lockdown they overrode
with a veto so Kansas no longer has a
lockdown but I wonder if the people do
you know if the people there are they're
like all cool let's all go ice skating
whatever they don't Kansas probably not
ice skating are they are the people
there getting the message and observing
in every state every state like that
yeah and the other thing is even the
states that do have lock downs the
lockdown orders have a page the waiver
and exemptions is like two pages long
right so you can visit grandma's you can
go fix your car in California by the way
there's also places where you can go you
know see a dermatologist because they're
for profit and they are you know are
still open are we doing enough here in
America I mean I can tell you what my
family lives in Israel and I hear there
are stories of what's going on there and
it sounds way different but it is so
much smaller that you're not different
now what's happening in
so for example it was just Passover now
and they knew that people are gonna want
to go to the Passover together with
their family so they closed all streets
Wow no one can go anywhere because it's
on the government level they ordered
everyone Passover for four references
like Chris for people who don't know is
like Christmas is for the Jews it's a
big holiday not as fun but not way less
fun yeah but it's the big one
or for example another example my sister
gave me she's at home with three kids
and she it's it gets really hard to
entertain them at some point she just
went downstairs to the street just to go
outside get some fresh air and a police
officer came to her and asked what what
is she doing outside why is she outside
and that's to see her ID and to make
sure she really lives there in that
building so in your opinion do you think
the United States is doing enough to
confront this no absolutely not our lock
downs are crappy but I think you know a
lock downs we can't have lock downs
forever obviously what we have to do is
lock down by the way our mitigations
their mitigations by definition just you
know a band-aid you know and what we
really need to do is testing testing
testing contact tracing quarantine and
by testing right now I don't mean like
testing when people get to the hospital
there's so many testing right now it's
like New York City they're so
overwhelmed they're only testing you if
you get to the hospital it's it's really
bad and so what you need to do is why
call frontier testing at the frontier
the moment someone develops their first
fever or chill or dry cough immediately
test them and after you immediately test
them immediately contact trace where
they've been um you know who are they
with is that even possible at the scope
that we've gotten here in the united we
have to slow it down obviously now in
Singapore and Korea they have mobile
apps that tells you you know even
you don't know someone that you were in
that person's basick like you got a
restaurant like you don't know who's at
the next table next to you but your
mobile phone would know that oh this
phone was in a proximity to that phone
for an extended period of time and so in
their app they would directly
communicate and tell the authorities
that this person was in vicinity of that
person years ago I actually built this
you know for all the people who thought
that you know I'm not infectious disease
out when they 2014 Ebola outbreak
happened under Obama's watch I was like
we have to build something like this
because you're never gonna know everyone
that you crossed has with in a
restaurant right so you need to have
something like you share your location
and then if the next day and you're
saved and next day if you or I test
positive the then you go back in the
record history and find in a path who
did you cross paths with in the last
seven days right and then for example if
we had and we didn't know each other in
a restaurant and the location markers
put us next to each other you know two
days ago then it would notify me with
all alert that you know Alan Eric was in
your vicinity two days ago but two days
later you tested positive okay so that's
how you do all of like advance contact
tracing and we might have to do that
right yeah so tell me I just saw your
knee are you wearing pants oh no I'm on
a podcast yeah no I don't expect it I
just saw your knee and I was like oh
yeah I love it yeah get comfortable so
let me ask you
it seems though that in the United
States we are seeing a flattening of the
curb and we are seeing dr. Falchi who is
credit who seems very credible right um
that he's lowering the death expectation
it's date by all accounts in the media
it seems to be working
do you what do you fourths forecast here
because it sounds like you're saying
well we're not doing enough but it does
seem like we're flattening the curve so
what do you what do you forecast here
first of all we're not doing enough
testing so do are we sure that we're
doing enough because in many parts of
country you know our testing is so
abysmal it's less than India or
Bangladesh right well it's on par with
that basically even now oh yeah Oklahoma
really low you know I saw a report you
can tell me just today that the federal
government was gonna stop funding state
tests oh yeah yep what is that they're
they're using that Oh states will take
over it the federal you know we want to
give States more control which is just
another cop-out for this for the federal
government to cut off the funding for
that I have no idea
it makes no sense the argument is very
yeah I was perplexed by that - I mean
that just seems very dangerous and
irresponsible I don't get it so the
testing here's the thing we're not doing
frontier testing if I was okay the other
thing is a how okay there's the cases
that test positive by the way the test
right now is only fifty percent accurate
so only 50 percent matter so which means
there's advanced there's a high false
negative there's a high false thing our
best test right now is only fifty
percent accurate
is that is that true of all the tests in
the world because I heard that the World
Health Organisation's test is like more
accurate than that it's always you know
even in China that the test was about 30
to 70 percent as 30 how is that helpful
at all I mean how does that help but how
does it better than anything if you put
if you're positive you're definitely
positive if you're negative
you could still be positive a few days
later there's almost dangerous to send
someone out right and be like you're
negative they'll go out more emboldened
and less cautious I know that's the
thing like these tests are deceiving
because it's it's not just a property of
the test it's also the property is virus
you know it's it's slow to build up its
viral load sometimes if you test early
you won't find it you know and so it's
kind of funky like that and also if some
people don't sample it properly some
people just sample it gently up the nose
you have to it's a very long stick it's
like almost like a chopstick length you
have to put it in your ugly nose and
then twist it horizontal to go all the
way back to like back here yeah does it
hurt and not everyone does it properly
and so it sounds awful and you don't do
it properly you don't get a positive
test because this virus lives in your
nasal pharynx so why is it that if
somebody breathes on me I get Corona but
but the doctors got a jam a rod all the
way down my nose together you bring it
up from there you coffee you talk yeah I
was saying you shake your vocal cords
and shake some particles loose to make
sound out of your mouth you know I've
also heard the ventilator is no walk in
the park either
that took going on a ventilator is
actually a very traumatic physical
experience on the body is that sometimes
they actually say you should use a lower
pressure because they're using too high
pressure on it what they do is they Jam
a tube into your lungs right so it's
it's not jammed through your vocal like
the intubation
the trick is to get it through your
vocal cords without destroying the vocal
cords so that's why you have to get you
that like long like little curved thing
are you unconscious when you're at
ventilated usually so so so it's pretty
you know people say oh we need a
ventilator but they don't understand how
severe it's a life-saving yeah it's a
life-saving but yeah I know
look this this virus is bad and so we
know the testing is imperfect we're not
doing frontier testing like Korea and
you know and Iceland were did so much
testing they did frontier testing and as
well as asymptomatic who's testing right
and so these kind of testing allows you
to like nip it in the bud early contact
trace early stop this has spread because
my time you have shortness of breath and
going you know let's just say it's one
week on average again some people are
longer than two weeks incubation one
week incubation on average and then you
have one week of fever and cough and
then on your second week second and a
half week then you start developing
shortness of breath and then you go to
the hospital baby I don't like you know
midway through that week you already
affected and you've already been sitting
so many other people potentially but if
you had frontier testing you would be
able to nip these in the bud find the
contact tracing much earlier and be able
stop it do you blame do you blame China
at all the government of China people
are referring it to as for example the
Chinese virus or the Wuhan virus or this
and that do you think that's an unfair
characteristic and do you think the
Chinese government could have done more
to stop this do they hold Rea any
responsibility for this becoming a
global pandemic to some degree I would
say like in some way this
you know I'm looking at the infectious
properties epidemic it is so damn
infectious right now that said
I am definitely not happy with what
China did because they try to silence
dr. Li when Leon the one who is a
whistleblower
they scag him he forcing the shut up be
punished in actually do that they know
they know about viruses that means they
worry about this virus so what do you
make of them them well what do you make
of that response it's just they allowed
it to spread right watch the instinct of
government is in politicians is oh no no
no let's keep any bad news on the deal
right and early on you they think that
if they keep it on deals like I'll take
care of it behind the scenes right we
don't need to panic the public will take
care of it and it's kind of like you
know I think of like Navy SEALs Navy
SEALs go on these clandestine missions
takes care of the things that the US
public does not want to know right all
right like we took care of the
terrorists we don't need to tell people
how close we know the terrorists got to
getting the bomb what is the downside of
panicking the public claims the panic is
the political outrage a you know it's a
structured society but also it basically
creates a an error that you know these
people are not a not competent oh you
let this happen because oftentimes
people have a tendency to blame any bad
thing on whoever's in charge at the
moment and some things are clearly out
of control like you know for example
Katrina you know hurricanes like [ __ ]
happens right but Katrina was a total
botch thing
oh but early on the Katrina they try to
actually cover up how badly they botched
a Katrina hurricane Katrina no it's just
a tendency for people to cover up their
their missteps so that you know it
doesn't look politically bad so you're
saying that even though China made an
effort to cover up this virus so
contagious I mean I irony the very
nature of it that it can infect people
before symptoms show
I I read something that you know half a
million people I had left Wuhan in a
diaspora around the world before China
even closed its borders so the
probability of it getting out was was
high regardless yeah it was bad there's
no getting around it with it
but do you think China could have
reacted sooner and there's been many
articles about it so could the China
have reacted sooner yes and could
reacting sooner have slowed down the
epidemic yes but would there still have
been an epidemic I still think there
would have been an epidemic maybe a
smaller epidemic and now are the Chinese
numbers completely accurate I doubt it
well I don't it's just like are you
lying that um if China had acted sooner
we would have a situation more akin to
SARS where it kind of just disappeared
eventually or do you think this is much
easier to contain because it didn't have
a symptomatic could you say there's be a
bit there'd be a much smaller endemic so
I wonder what does that look like
compared to what we're faced with today
well we had 2000 we had the 2009 h1n1
pandemic and you know we've had these
but again some years they were more well
contained and though each one anyone
could have easily been overwhelmed the
world as well Hadley not reacted faster
and Ebola could have been not contained
and so the other thing is didn't wh oh
like how much fault is wh o have i think
w to here by the way most the people who
i know so well know the organization for
those who uh world health organization
it's it it's like it's a body of the UN
so division of the UN focus on health
right now I recall you screaming at them
to declare a global emergency or they
they were slow to the the draw as well
the tendency of a lot of these leaders
is scientific bodies is they don't act
until they absolutely certain and but
there you know the preparedness head dr.
Mike Ryan actually has it right if you
want to be perfectly sure about
something before you act if you wanted
to have all the facts in completely you
know solid in as hard as rock certain
before you act on something you will
always be too late and so that's the
other thing like in science a lot of the
you know the academia types like well
that was one preliminary study we need
compliment it wasn't peer-reviewed he
needs to be confirmed by multiple
studies and in many situations and of
you know we still don't know
asymptomatic you know for example whu-oh
had declared we do not know about he
certainty that's human to human to
Russian yeah but there's so many
anecdotes that clear made it clear it
was pretty human to human by the way I
remember they they had sent out a tweet
saying the threat of a global pandemic
is very low and if you're outside Wuhan
you shouldn't be worrying about this
that and was already in Washington I
remember that and so I was like wow
these this this they should really be
failing us in this moment because I
think a lot of people let's say people
who are even distrustful of what our
government tells us or the Chinese
government tells us would look to a body
like World Health Organization and take
what they say credibly like and it's
it's extremely frustrating because they
it's these big organizations are very
bureaucratic in their so conservative
you don't want to jump the gun on
something and it's really weird like for
example France recently jumped the gun
on something that told people in the
middle of this epidemic stop taking
ibuprofen stop taking advil motrin you
stop it because it suppresses your fever
yes but actually suppressing your fever
suppresses your inflammatory immune
response and allows the epidemic to grow
even faster
and so fret the French Ministry said
everybody stopped taking ibuprofen
period for any fever and the W chill
waffled like no wait there's not enough
evidence and then they kind of
wishy-washy given evidence like if
you're not taking it you know you don't
try some other options first if you're
already taking it continue to take it
it's it gives a wishy-washy evidence
well France just went stopped taking and
out of precaution you know how like
there's like this out of abundance of
caution we're gonna do this other thing
right there's more aggressive you have
to act fast I mean sometimes you need to
act decisively act without 100 percent
certainty it's a trust you're like the
you have to read the tea leaves before
it becomes a full tree right you know
you can't wait until all the signal is
like you're blazing red in a siren
before you act is by then it's already
here by the way ibuprofen for people
listening is safe to take right I read
something that that that that was found
not to make it worse this is where the
grain is there is yeah
so the grain is France says don't do it
WH o gave this measly answer that says
if you're not taking it already try
other fever reducing medicines people
should be people should be careful
consuming ibuprofen right now
are you asking me where if I was to WH
I'm asking you I'm not a clinician but I
you know I've I've studied I become for
many years ibuprofen is known to cause
heart attacks by the way just like my ox
to some degree I haven't proven it like
the way I'm interpreting WTO's
guidelines the way they phrased it in
this really weird like cryptic way that
you know you shouldn't take it if you
should treat you should try to take
other things that you can but you didn't
say don't take it you say take other
things if you can and knowing that
that's wh oh I would I would probably
you know follow the French device and
not take don't take it that's that's it
don't take it I'm just saying my gut
instinct is I'm reading between the
lines in it and it W Cho does have doubt
but they're trying to hedge their bets
right and so like it's like if someone
asked me this core can work we don't
know for sure if it works right our
mechanisms are there really good case
reports that does work yes at the same
time are there cases reports that are
people having extreme reactions that the
Swedish government says stop we're not
doing the offering chloroquine for any
patients in our Swedish hospitals that's
also very valid so I think if you are
gonna ask my prediction I think Laura
can probably works to a limited degree
for some people but in the trial that's
gonna come out someday I bet there's
gonna be huge adverse reactions that
could offset the benefits if you click
it do you find it bizarre how
how heavily the president the president
Trump is promoting the stroke it's or
he's just giving people hope do you find
thing he's just giving hope or is it
just it seems so bizarre for the
president to be so strongly pushing one
specific drug yeah it is weird it's kind
of like just giving people everything
out there he he's it's it's like sound
bites and like selective information the
Trump wants the food truck always wants
to hear what he likes to hear right no
like that's that's pretty obvious you
don't have to be political on the left
or right everyone can tell us comforting
to know hey there's oh if you're
listening to the president there's this
miracle treatment out there and the
president probably is told by someone Oh
in this one report it did work it's like
oh great it does work but he doesn't
know how how science works in which yeah
okay you know you it's like finding
there are people like James burns he
lived to a hundred smoked a cigar and
like cigarette all these cigarettes a
day and drank whiskey everyday he lived
a hundred years old if you took that as
an anecdote and you can play find lots
of people who smoked and live to like 90
or 100 right it's like oh look he lived
to 90 years old 100 years old and smoked
a pack of cigarettes a day are you gonna
buy those people absolutely but is that
the overall picture that's no because
overall picture is that you know smoking
cigarettes causes heart attacks and lung
cancer and other cancers when you're
always gonna find these extreme like oh
wow amazing 100 years old person smoke
the pack of cigarettes I want to ask you
I want to zoom out a little bit because
the whole concept of a virus is very
bizarre can you tell me what what is a
virus a virus is actually not alive it's
a particle of either an RNA or DNA with
a code it's just a pure piece of a strip
of code covered in the envelope okay
which is by the way the envelope is
built by the code inside it cannot
replicate on its own it can
reproduce it does not eat anything it
does not poop anything all it does is it
needs to find an something
another hosts cell factory so that you
could slip in while the factories
running me you know your own cell
producing your own proteins slip its
code in there and make the the cells
machinery read the code and make the
viruses proteins which and so the virus
is not alive it is just a piece of code
gone wild it is it is no it does not
think of its own it survives only to
maximize its chance of slipping into
another host and forcing the host to
make its own proteins for that seems so
bizarre to me that it's not alive yet it
has like when you when you when you
think of bacteria for example it's
living and it and it reproduces but how
can something not be alive yet seek to
reproduce itself it's just very weird
doesn't seek it's just it's an it's an
eight it's a it's a function of
evolution right if it dot if if it had a
crappy piece of code or if it's junk
code it's not gonna go anywhere right
it's not going to reproduce itself and
it's gonna die out so after billions and
trillions of copies and billions and
trillions and mutations it's gonna
tinker it itself in a way that is
readable by the host cell and it's gonna
make in this readable code is gonna make
something that will help us survive
anything that selects for all these
things will therefore live that is life
too that is also kind of in a way what
we do right like think about it
our ancestors so now we are here because
someone gave birth to us and if our
ancestor was infertile was castrated
in battle or had some sort in polycystic
ovarian syndrome to make their ovaries
infertile we would not be here right
we are the Selective reason for this and
I think the best reason is look name the
vitamin that has caused the most Wars
and strife in human civilization
can you name it the vitamin name a
vitamin or mineral that is caused more
warm strife and human suffering than any
other vitamin I don't know it's vitamin
D the reason is the reason that Nordic
people have lighter skin Middle Eastern
people have medium brown skin and
Africans have dark skin is that the more
north you go the less sunlight you get
direct sunlight that's why those it's
colder up in the Arctic Circle but
that's also why there are more blondes
fair-skinned light-skinned people in
Norway Denmark and Scotland and Sweden
then there are in Italy in Turkey and
Greece or Middle East the reason for
that is the dark the dark skin prevents
you from making as much vitamin D so as
these humans have left out of Africa
which is we can we know that from DNA
it's in the code you can't get away from
that and they migrated from the Middle
East to Italy to northern Europe to the
Nordic countries they had to evolve
lighter skin hmm
and the only reason they did that was so
that their skin can continue to make
vitamin D from the Sun because a dark
skin in in Norway would never make
enough vitamin D in the Norwegian Sun
what interesting and so in certain ways
we evolved lighter skin and and
everything else from it racism all these
other kind of things that we'd identify
with our tribal nature is because we
evolved that so the same
season are we evolved lighter-skinned in
northern latitudes and darker-skinned at
the equator it is the same driving force
because we need vitamin D and if you
don't evolve vitamin E lighter-skinned
in northern latitudes you will die
because you will not get enough vitamin
D you will die and over time you select
for only people who have enough
light-skinned mutations that led to
their survival in the Nordic countries
and that's the same reason the virus
survives because it just it knows
nothing but random gibberish of codes
but out of all these random gibberish or
mutations it will select the best thing
that will allow it to survive and that
is over time becomes the perfect ball
just a total random number generator
running on another generator but is
selected for survival by the forces or
whatever around which it looks but where
does it come from how does a virus well
how did the first virus come into being
I mean where do these things come from
what is it I mean I just oh you said
what is it but like not like I mean what
how did it come to be that these things
are floating around but that's that's a
really good question you also ask how do
we come into being from primordial soup
but it's it's it seems almost so I
didn't so the the origin of the viruses
as mysterious as life itself and it even
seems to be almost like an antithesis of
life as we know it almost but it is part
of the world you know it we are the same
evolutionary functions that drove us to
be from you know quadrupedal to bipedal
because bipedal people can run faster
these things of forces allow us to
survive and I think that is the ultimate
evolutionary message you know I
unfortunately have two leaps ok good I'm
coming - I'm coming - how much time do
you have left
Oh probably 5 minutes so let me ask you
this then briefly let's let's close it
up here what
if you have an what are the
misconceptions what do people need to
know from you right now to protect
themselves what are the most important
things they need to do to make this
better for them and and really as us as
for the country what do we need to know
I think what we need to know is look we
need to do testing we need to basically
know that certain people have more
susceptibility right if you are diabetes
high blood pressure heart disease any
lung disease any immuno immunity disease
you should be extra extra careful in
addition to if your hold because you
know a lot of people are asymptomatic
and healthy and mild but if you have any
of these things like I said a diabetic
person has 17 times higher chance of
being ICU emitted than someone who's not
and these are the realities we have to
know these risk factors would at the
same time this virus you know if we lift
up the lockdown we're gonna have a
resurgence we're gonna have to find a
way to identify everyone who has been
previous built up immunity that's the
Asaro testing of virus antibodies and
there's really good evidence that if you
someone who has survived give donates
their plasma to someone who is sick he
actually improves their element not a
randomized trial yet but good anecdotal
evidence that a lot of people believe
and these things basically those who
have had an immunity can potentially go
back to work someday and we're gonna
find ways that if you are super healthy
zero risk factors or you have immunity
we can find ways for these people to go
back to work and we can open restaurants
and movies and movie theaters soon but
but we have to find ways in which to do
it slowly we cannot reopen have sports
games again and full capacity movie
theaters again those are the days of the
past until we have a vaccine we just
simply cannot do that and so we will get
through this it will t wheel it will
change our society forever the year took
the 20/20 will be
here in which our society evolves to a
higher level of appreciation for
universal healthcare potentially that
you know actually giving that guy
healthcare make sure he doesn't get sick
he's actually protects me and my family
I think people are finally waking up I
better pay for uh I have government pay
for his healthcare his co vid his
treatment so that he doesn't keep
infecting me oh because he can't afford
to go to hospital and get organ tested
right
I think will have huge ramifications
there in terms of away we see a society
and I see a lot of conservatives coming
around to that to finally I don't want
to keep you too long I want to ask you
one last question cuz I know you're in a
hurry so I don't I don't want to mess up
your schedule can i order our food yes I
would sanitize it when you cut when it
comes in your house how either with our
bleach wipe or you you there's UV wands
by the way are really good wine light
kills the but you know I gotta get a UV
one those off you lights or UV lamps and
the other thing is your food a microwave
instantly kills things microwaves a food
if you don't counter microwave your
salad but what you orders of cook food
how long how long do I need to microwave
it yeah 15 30 seconds for be enough
what about groceries when you come back
home with groceries this is the weird
thing yeah if you don't trust it wash it
with soap if you can you know like
washer melon with soap if you really
want it but you can obviously can't
microwave your soap you can use a UV one
over it if you really want to um I mean
should you really wipe every bag every
package that you bring into the house
look about okay OCD are you like well
what's the risk level in your in your
opinion is there a risk there or if
you're immunocompromised I would do that
yeah if you're young and you don't have
risk factors okay maybe you can you know
of be less gung-ho hardcore in fact if I
order this shirt online and it arrived
can I wear it
yeah virus does not survive that long
their body does not survive longer than
three days on on this is good
information biotic sand and stainless
steel one day on cardboard and paper so
and again high temperature and humidity
always kills it bastard
okay so heat is your friend you know is
the summer gonna wipe is the summer
gonna reduce the spread to some degree
but again you know summer here is winter
or down in southern atmosphere so
there's no it doesn't happen thing is
the other thing is we're indoor people
we go to comic-con conventions and hotel
meetings and workplaces are
air-conditioned than summer it makes no
difference so in in in many ways you
know it's it will not go away it will
have a resurgence in the fall I'm pretty
sure but hopefully by then we'll have a
plan we'll have 2021 that's the future
the vaccines will hopefully arrive in 12
to 18 months which means hopefully
February 2021 earliest but maybe spring
of 2021 so how do we make how do we make
billions of vaccines I guess we've
already done it you've already kind of
ramped up ready to we like Bill Gates
has donated billions of dollars he's
saying we're building seven factories
ready to build whichever vaccine is six
nice that's nice good job bill yeah also
you know like you know know CEO Twitter
horsey horsey you don't need that
billion dollars 90 percent of as well
yeah that's ballsy if we want to donate
what is your opinion and good place to
donate to donate blood
that's right now really really yes can i
buy it can i buy it can I pay poor
people to go donate blood no they need
your blood especially if you survive the
virus they really need your blood some
bit I'm right for everyman whatever
they're ready for them all right I'll
donate
can I pay Zack to go donate blood is
that just as good but is it safe to go
and donate blood the one you need to be
if you don't have it this is the big
thing so there's no clear answers
there's no black and white answers in
this epidemic so well dog you want just
be safe we've we've said it all smart
we've done it all we've talked about it
all we've learned we've listened then I
thank you so much for being here with us
and sharing your knowledge with us what
do you have next BBC yeah
BBC they're calling me on skype at the
same time so okay well you better take
that call yeah let's so let's hopefully
meet up and do a in-person one on the
flip side words right when you can fly
again yeah that's a good point well okay
well thank you very much thank you for
spreading information and doing all
these interviews and everything I know
you're probably busy as hell but you're
doing a public service so thank you very
much we really appreciate it thank you
all right
[Music]